president Trump apparently is starting  to sweat the 2020 election he's thinking  about it he's getting a little nervous I  think it has come out that this is true  president Trump's campaign strategy is  to paint Joe Biden as feeble that's what  they're gonna try and do yeah and Biden  strategy is to portray President Trump  as president Trump so the parallel  strategy see if it works this was crazy  it was reported in the paper today that  after Kim jong-un found out his older  brother was a spy for the CIA he had him  executed yes I disagree with everything  Kim jong-un does or says but as a little  brother I get it wait a minute don't  murder yeah fratricide yeah Bradley  Cooper and his fiancee broke up which  means he is officially single yeah yeah  I read about it on Twitter and then last  night my wife murmured it in her sleep  don't applaud for that  that really did happen all right